[Music]
after nearly two years of behaving like
a man under siege Donald Trump is acting
like a leader who's just won the
ultimate battle no collusion no
obstruction there never was by the way
and there never will be
what I said in front of my friends this
should never happen to another president
again this hoax should never happen to
another president again Robert mallas
investigation paints a decidedly mixed
picture mr. Trump's Attorney General
providing his own account of the 448
page report before Congress could see it
as the Special Counsel report makes
clear the Russian government sought to
interfere in our election process but
thanks to the special counsels thorough
investigation we now know that the
Russian operatives who perpetrated these
schemes did not have the cooperation of
President Trump or the Trump campaign or
the knowing assistants of any other
American for that matter that is
something that all Americans can and
should be grateful to have confirmed red
flags all red herrings we did get
revelations when Donald Trump heard that
Robert mullah had been appointed he
reportedly slumped in his chair and told
his attorney general Jeff Sessions oh my
god this is terrible this is the end of
my presidency followed by an expletive
he also allegedly asked his lawyer to
get Muller quote removed the suggestion
in the lengthy document is that mr.
Trump tried to obstruct justice but his
colleagues wouldn't help him the
president's effort to influence the
investigation the report says were
mostly unsuccessful but that is largely
because the persons who surrounded the
president declined to carry out a recede
to his requests and on one central issue
the investigators claimed they simply
couldn't reach the legal bar the
evidence we obtained about the
president's actions and intent presents
difficult issues that prevent us from
conclusively determining that no
criminal conduct occurs
accordingly while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him
there was plenty of contact with
Russians but no criminal conspiracy and
the president's team say he only did
what he was entitled to do the report
suggests that Donald Trump did try to
get rid of Robert Mother that that was
an attempted obstruction of justice the
president had the complete right to fire
Muller if he wanted to get rid of Muller
he could just fire him he doesn't need
to do anything else he could just fire
him the way he fired Comey has the
constitutional right to do that that is
far from enough to satisfy the Democrats
it is clear the special counsel's office
conducted an incredibly thorough
investigation in order to preserve the
evidence for future investigators the
special counsel made clear that he did
not exonerate the president and the
responsibility now Falls to Congress to
hold the president accountable for his
actions both sides vainly been further
pushed apart by today's report but
Donald Trump who cast it as a hoax from
the start now sees it as cause for
celebration Donald Trump isn't letting
go of this investigation already
channeling gameofthrones
and his opponents or haters as he calls
them won't be giving up either
they may have questions he made a point
of leaving for Florida without answering
any Cordelia left sty News Washington